-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
and let's get to the news.
Facebook went offline yesterday
for over six hours.
Wow, they finally
found something
they couldn't fix
with horse paste.
[ Laughter ]
Facebook apologized yesterday
after all three
of its social media platforms
went offline for six hours
and said it was due
to a "faulty
configuration change,"
adding, "after a quick reboot,
he started working again."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
that he couldn't guarantee
that the federal government
will not default on debt
payments due later this month.
So, in addition to everything
else going on, we've now entered
the "Uncut Gems" phase
of his presidency.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, he's on the phone
to de Blasio, saying --
[ As Biden ]
Put all of Montana on red!
[ Laughter ]
During a Zoom session yesterday
with the
House Progressive Caucus,
President Biden reportedly said
that he's frustrated
with Senators
Joe Manchin and Kyrsten Sinema.
Well, you know it's bad when
a 78-year-old man is on Zoom
and that's not
the frustrating part.
[ Laughter ]
During a briefing yesterday,
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki showed a chart
of how much debt was accumulated
under former President Trump
and said, "Republicans spent
like drunken sailors
over the last four years."
And, in some cases,
they also looked like them.
[ Laughter ]
Former White House Press
Secretary Stephanie Grisham's
book was released today.
Find it in the
Complicit But Needs Money
section.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Times published
an op-ed yesterday titled
"What's Wrong
With Kyrsten Sinema?"
Well, for one thing,
I think she may be color blind?
[ Laughter ]
Former presidential candidate
Andrew Yang announced yesterday
that he has changed
his voting registration
from Democrat to Independent,
raising the question,
"If a tree falls in the woods,
can we listen to that,
instead of Andrew Yang?"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
the rights to the Folgers
"The best part of waking up"
jingle
recently sold at auction
for more than $90,000,
while the Kars4Kids jingle
was taken out back
and shot in the head.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue.